and to make that wait a little less
painful for you I can already tell you
that tennis has since made it through to
the next round she's received a call
from both the tourism firm and the
discount store made in Germany wishes
her all the best now to all of the other
young Europeans waiting in line for a
job it's the focus this week of a mini
summit on youth unemployment in Berlin
attended by the blocks leaders to tell
us more about the situation we're joined
by yuliya burn Kerr from the German
trade union very good to have you along
nice to be here first of all how dire is
the situation are we really talking
about a lost generation yes I think Kyle
occurs where thousands of young people
and unemployment and also the ones who
are in jobs are in precarious jobs their
data mine jobs are low paid this can all
be changed I hope so i guess it's it
would be needed more investments and
subsidies in the lender who are affected
by the crisis the country's an effective
what about who's responsible who is
actually or what is responsible well I
guess in this specific situation it's um
the fiscal policy of your the European
Union plays big role because the
countries can invest in the economy
which also effects the market of
vocational training places ok well let's
bring up the latest figures for you it
doesn't get any worse than Greece of
course if you take a look at the numbers
the right there has hit almost sixty
percent which is staggering Spain isn't
all that far behind portugal is now over
forty percent while youth unemployment
in germany is only at seven point six
percent as we know a lot of people are
moving from the south to germany for
work what sort of implications does this
huge shift have well i would say that it
can't be very good for the economies in
for spain or grin or Greece because if
you take out a large number of good
qualified people out of the economy how
can it get out of the crisis on its own
so the situation just gets
were somewhere else probably what about
vocational training is is that providing
a way out definitely I think so this is
something that should be looked at it's
better the vocational training system in
Germany is based on the on the work came
together from companies the state and
social partners so yeah this is the
specialty of it but surely this can
cause resentment in Germany the Left
Party for example is piping up causing
opposition saying that it's going to
create an unfair situation well it kind
of does because they are also young
people in Germany who still seeking for
a job and a vocational training place
but actually I think it shouldn't matter
from which country an applicant for
vocational training place came from but
why are their positions here that aren't
being filled well I think in some
sectors like for example the hotels
restaurants or the hairdressing sector
their bed working and training
conditions actually their trainees were
more used as cheap labor instead of
wheeling learning a craft what do you
think about speed dating coming back to
our report well I'm glad it worked for
tennis but I would prefer the regular
way off yeah applicants and obviously
that's not enough to solve the problems
in the south a major structural changes
needed yes definitely first of all we
need a good working and training
conditions in Germany but also in the
South European countries and a youth
guarantee would be good for like a right
for everybody who leaves school to get
in vocational training for example you
do boneco thank you very much for the
analysis thank you
you